[موسيقى]
تعرف على أمي هي منظمة مقرها
باريس
أنشأناها تلتقي بأمي قبل أربع سنوات ،
لقد نشأنا جميعًا على يد نساء لديهن هدية
للطهي واكتشفنا أن هؤلاء النساء
لم يُرَ عندما تذهب إلى المطاعم الكبيرة أو الفاخرة
عندما تشاهد التلفاز
وتشاهد عرضًا للطهي ، فأنت لا ترى
هؤلاء النساء ، لذلك قررنا التحدث إلى
هؤلاء النساء واكتشفنا أن هؤلاء
النساء لديهن حواجز تمنعهن
من فعل ما يحلو لهن في الطهي ،
فقد يكون ذلك عائقًا أمام  اللغة
يمكن أن تكون حواجز اقتصادية ، يمكن أن تكون
الثقة بالنفس
لتمكين هؤلاء النساء من العيش من خلال
شغفهن بالطهي لتمكين هؤلاء النساء
من إدراك أن مهاراتهن يمكنهن
العيش من خلال تلك المهارات التي أنشأناها
برنامج تمكين فريد من نوعه
مع برنامج تمكين مع  طريقة فريدة
نلهمهم من خلال الأحداث التي ندربهم
عليها من خلال أكاديمية ماما
ونجعلهم يدركون أن هذه المهارات هي
أهدافنا الحقيقية ونحن فقط نقوم
بإضفاء المزيد من الاحتراف على هذه المهارات
حتى يكون لدينا مطبخ  يمكنهم الطهي
حيث يمكنهم التدريب وحيث يمكنهم
بدء أعمالهم الخاصة في مجال تقديم الطعام
وعندما يكونون مستعدين يصبحون
مستقلين ، والهدف هو أن تتمكن من العيش
بشغفها بحيث يكون لديها عملاء من
منصتنا ويمكنها كسب المال كل
شهر
في  يلتقي بأمي ، لدينا العديد من المأكولات
لدينا ماما تأتي من
أمريكا اللاتينية والشرق الأوسط وشمال أوروبا وآسيا
وأفريقيا
في السنوات القليلة الماضية ، ونأمل أن نتوسع مع
والدتي في جميع أنحاء العالم في الشرق الأوسط
في شمال إفريقيا
منذ عامين قررنا
التقديم  للحصول على جائزة لتكون
قادة إكسبو 2020 مبتكرين ووجدنا أنه
تم
اختيارنا وأننا فخورون حقًا وهي بالنسبة
لنا فرصة فريدة لجعلهم
موجودين لجعل صوتهم في جميع أنحاء
العالم والسماح لجميع النساء في العالم
بالحلم  حول أن تصبح صانعًا لتحديات الطعام
لأنهم يستطيعون فعل ذلك
عنك